I press play and he loved the song He's
like I love the song this is good like I
think a month later I said it to him and
I was like hey just sending you this if
you want to listen to it if you want to
check it out since you said you liked it
did you say you liked it you listen to
it in your car your bike ride at the gym
like whatever you want and um yeah it
just ended up working out like that like
he ended up liking the song enough that
he wanted to put a verse on it and I was
so happy about that because like look at
that verse it's like one of my favorite
verses of all time oh he killed it he
got off how could I just seen this one
and that one I could have both oh my God
he got oh he did not give you the
throwaway covers so I wasn't
overthinking or like pushing my pen to
the to the bars like expecting to get J
Cole on that song So when he put his
verse on it I'm like I'm gonna go redo
my verse they're like he's like no no no
they wouldn't they told me not to they
were not supposed to do it yeah that's
kind of like uh cheating but like yeah I
was like bro like who who thinks when
they cut like a random reference that
Cole's gonna be on that song yeah it's
crazy I think that's against like unsaid
rap rules too